it's time for a deep dive number five
and it's Tesla the electric carmaker
reported last week that it sold more
than ten thousand Model S cars in the
first quarter a 55% increase from a year
earlier and yesterday it announced that
buyers will have to pony up a little bit
more for Tesla's least expensive car
which is now being called the Model S
70d it starts around seventy-five
thousand which is five grand more than
the Model S sixty that it sold it has a
range of 240 miles and tops out at 140
miles an hour so more range and I'm
guessing all-wheel drive as well
Bloomberg's Jamie butters the Detroit
Bureau auto editor joins us and Jamie is
this an all-wheel drive is the D is that
what the D means dual power right yeah
the the D is the the the dual motor
all-wheel drive that was a much hyped
last fall right who's gonna unveil the D
and it turned out it's the the dual
motor and and that's really where luxury
buyers are at least certainly in North
America so many are in the Northeast and
even you know Chicago and and places
like that where we get a lot of snow we
get a lot of bad weather people really
and especially the boomers that really
come up feeling you know rear-wheel
drive was fun when they were kids but
front-wheel drive has more safety and
more balance and all-wheel drive is
really the best thing and that's what
you're seeing so much in luxury so
that's where their buyers are going and
that's where Tesla's moving now I want
to say on a personal aside Jamie that I
feel like with the right tires a wheel
rear wheel drive car is fine through the
winter but that aside
obviously consumers are obviously
consumers want all-wheel drive and the
p85d the the most expensive Tesla with
with the four-wheel drive had like 700
horsepower right so does this get a
boost also in power it definitely has
the extra range compared to the 60 the
thing is is like you guys were talking
about the iPhones on the last play I
mean it's just like with iPhones nobody
buys the iPhone with the smallest
battery possible because they don't want
one year from now they have a phone
that's perfectly fine except they can't
run the apps
it and I think that's been the that's
been the way with sales of the Model S
everyone's buying the if it's not the
p85d because maybe they don't all need
all that power but they're getting the
eighty-five they're getting they want
the most range possible most people who
can afford a 70 or 80 thousand dollar
car can probably afford a hundred
thousand dollar car if 80 is a stretch
for them they might just buy you know
Alexis or Mercedes gets on you know BMW
5-series and stay you know comfortable
let me ask you about the price Jamie let
me ask you about the price we say
seventy-five thousand dollars to start
tell you I suspect a Tesla for myself on
the website and I could not get the
price to be lower than 120 I think it
was really more like a hundred thirty
thousand dollars of course I was
expecting the highest the p85 at the
time but this one I'm guessing the same
will be true when you when you actually
build your own model on the configurator
it's not going to be 75 grand yeah
you're right I mean no of course you'll
get some discounts you'll get the 7500
from the federal government depending on
where your income falls you might get
some local discounts or state government
discounts but then you're gonna add on
the options you're gonna want all the
all the tricks all the doodads all the
apps and that's gonna it's gonna add up
tens of thousands to the to the final
price and so the thing is though right
you know Elon Musk has been wanting to
electrify the personal transportation
right and get us break us off our
addiction to oil and and going higher
and higher upscale kind of seems to take
it away from that but I think what it's
really doing is kind of opening more
space for that Model 3 that's coming a
couple years down the road because that
we hear the price thirty five thousand
dollars there's something in that range
but people are gonna load it up and it's
gonna end up being a fifty fifty five
sixty thousand dollar car maybe and then
you're getting awfully close to those
bottom Model S's that you don't really
want to see the S keep coming down or it
really puts pressure on what they can
sell two three four I see so he wants to
get put out a model eventually closer to
volt prices meanwhile he's been trying
to put out this Model X for so long and
pushing back the date for so long I
can't remember we're not supposed to
come out but now when are we looking for
this the SUV
yeah the the SUV is supposed to come in
August they've been consistent with that
since November so that's the plan and
and they've kept reaffirming that it's
coming of course the question then is
when will we see it you know we're
through the major Auto Show season Tesla
doesn't usually part sometimes they
participate in shows sometimes they
don't but it's not where they reveal
their products they try to have their
their own events kind of more like Apple
have a special Tesla van I mean they had
a whole event just to say that they were
bringing all-wheel-drive to their model
so I think we'll see another big show
like that in Hawthorne or Palo Alto or
someplace like that all right very cool
I guess Elon Musk no matter what you
want to say about him he's always
interesting and we're always talking
about it everybody loves talking about
Tesla and the cars have you driven one
Jaime have you driven a Tesla Model S
just a very little bit but it's pretty
spectacular it's awesome all right Jaime
butters from our destroyed Bureau thanks
very much for joining us